bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
nous voici à strasbourg au parlement
européen
un reportage de cette semaine nous
emmène en grèce où la crise sociale
s'aggrave
le taux de chômage explose la grèce où
le gouvernement a décidé sans prévenir
personne de fermer la télévision
publique
mais d'abord l'actualité après plusieurs
années de récession 57 millions
d'européens vivent sous le seuil de
pauvreté alors l'europe s'enfonce tel
dans la misère c'est la question de la
semaine émeutes manifestations colère
ces trajets sont des histoires dernier
rempart de la lutte contre
étais je
ses cris du peuple en grèce au portugal
en espagne en irlande aussi c'est à
chypre finalement on s'y habituerait
presque depuis cinq ans les débuts de la
crise l'an pas vraiment retour à la case
misère pour l'union européenne
les bulles immobilières ont explosé et
jeté dans les rues des familles entières
et en attendant on regarde mourir des
villages fantômes
même les autoroutes sont désertés alors
que le fmi avoue que le plan de
sauvetage en grèce fait une erreur voilà
qu'on nous annonce la fin de l'austérité
mais pas de panique
elle continue la rigueur budgétaire faut
pas pousser
alors est ce le retour de la misère en
europe
et nous voilà de retour à strasbourg au
parlement européen nous allons donc
parler de retour de la misère en europe
et pour évoquer cette question c'est
karima delli qui est avec nos bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne
membre du groupe des verts ale vous êtes
surtout membre de la commission de
l'emploi et des affaires sociales
et comme vous voyez ces images d'émeutes
de manifestation quand vous voyez par
exemple la grèce est en récession depuis
plus de cinq ans maintenant qu'est-ce
que ça vous évoque est ce que on a
régressé au niveau des conditions de vie
au sein de l'union européenne
la précarité a explosé la pauvreté
explosé et ça concerne toutes les
catégories de population que ce soit les
jeunes les retraités et même les
familles monoparentales aujourd'hui et
donc ça veut dire que le cap qu'on s'est
donné notamment le caf que la commission
et les chefs d'état c'est à dire le
cadre de l'austérité n'est pas le bon
cap aujourd'hui il faut penser plutôt à
des investissements pas à couper dans
les dépenses mais véritablement investir
pour pouvoir redonner un peu et sports à
l'ensemble des populations et créer des
filets de sécurité et à ce moment là on
verra réellement qu'une bouffée
d'oxygène
et quand je parle de filets de sécurité
on ne peut pas parler de la pauvreté et
ni de la misère sans les populations
parce que malheureusement souvent fait
pour elle
alors qu'aujourd'hui vous faire avec
elle là vous venez de rendre un rapport
qui a été saluée si je puis dire sauf il
a été il a eu du mal à être votée sur la
question du logement en europe le
logement en europe n'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne et de
surcroît le parlement européen
n'a pas vocation en fait à proposer des
directives est ce que c'est un pavé dans
la mare c'est un pavé dans la main c'est
la première fois que le parlement
s'engage de manière aussi claire pour
dire nous avons besoin du logement
social le logement ce n'est pas une
compétence de l'union européenne mais
nous avons le droit à une aide au
logement c'est une obligation puisque
c'est un droit qui est reconnu par la
charte des droits fondamentaux et que
lui le logement intervient sur
différents au domaine d'efficacité
énergétique le volet emploi
le volet lutte contre l'exclusion le
volet également servi d'intérêt général
est d'état etc et dans mon rapport
justement pour la première fois les
députés européens demandent un cadre
européen des politiques du logement
notamment du logement social pour
véritablement avancé pour plus de
logements sociaux mais aussi inventé sur
cette europe sociale là vous avez pointé
dans ce rapport la question de la
spéculation immobilière et les bulles on
l'a vu notamment l'irlande on l'a vu en
espagne surtout on assiste en fait à des
on voit aujourd'hui des villages
fantômes qui sont complètement vide on
estime qu'il ya 700 mille logements en
espagne qui sont aujourd'hui inoccupés
laon l'état aujourd'hui comment vous
régler cette question là alors très
simplement le rapport dit bien que plus
on aura un parc de logements sociaux
importants plus on va éviter les bulles
immobilières ça veut dire que vous dites
stop aux propriétaires quoi on dit
réellement aujourd'hui il faut plus de
logements sociaux parce que c'est un
véritable levier pour lutter contre la
crise sociale la crise économique mais
aussi la crise écologique et face
notamment à un vrai problème vous
évoquez notamment l'espagne aujourd'hui
dans le rapport ont dit clairement que
il faut lutter contre les expulsions
notamment des familles qui n'arrivent
plus à payer leurs crédits hypothécaires
ça a été reconnue notamment par la cour
européenne de justice ait reconnu par le
parlement européen
maintenant mais les soigne aussi a voté
un moratoire de deux ans sur les
expulsions vous vous avec ceux ci soient
généralisable sur tout le territoire à
la roma on a plusieurs expérimentations
niveau européen on a essayé de le
demander notamment de mettre en place
justement des politiques de prévention
et d'éviter les expulsions on l'a on
s'est battus au parlement mais
malheureusement les conservateurs
et les libéraux sont encore dans une
logique du tous propriétaires qui
malheureusement nous emmène à on est
dans le mur et n'a pas été adopté mais
cela n'est pas très grave puisque dans
le rapport on trouve également une
protection qui est majeur notamment pour
les populations les plus les plus
précaires notamment c'est de lutter
contre la vacance des logements
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas assez de
logements sociaux
il faut construire dont il faut lutter
contre la vacance des logements et pour
la première fois le parlement européen
demande à l'ensemble des états membres
de fixer un quota minimum de logements
sociaux notamment dans les zones tendues
vous voyez là on veut dire en gros une
application de la loi sru comme telle
qu'on la connaît la rance qui oblige en
fait les communes et avoir 25 % de
logements sociaux sur leur territoire
mais cela au niveau européen voilà que
si je comprends bien vous la militante
de jeudi noir qui est donc une
association qui se posent sur ce champ
du logement et notamment du logement
social
vous êtes en train de donner plutôt un
satisfecit à la france sur la manière
dont elle gère la question du logement
on peut faire crédit à la france qu'elle
avance notamment sur cette question de
logement social mais elle ne va pas
assez loin parce qu'on ne construit pas
on n'est pas aujourd'hui dans les
objectifs à atteindre malheureusement va
pas les atteindre 7 cette année
et moi je tire la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le fait qu'en france il fait aussi
beaucoup plus de logements très sociaux
parce que malheureusement l'accès à des
logements sociaux est de plus en plus un
parcours du combattant pour les jeunes
les plus précaires les plus pauvres on
voit bien quand même qu'on est dans une
conjoncture budgétaire très contraint
le budget européen qui sera peut-être en
passe d'être adopté le mois prochain
baisse considérablement les crédits au
fond est-ce qu'on peut pas dire que
votre rapport et ses voeux de deux de
pointe et les fonds structurels sur la
question du logement sur cette précarité
énergétique est ce que c'est pas un voeu
pieux c'était un peu mieux parce que
d'une part l'union européenne investit
déjà bien les fonds structurels dans le
logement au social
aujourd'hui nous sommes en pleine
négociation notamment sur le fléchage
des fonds européens oui ce sera une
priorité
l'union européenne va investir davantage
les fonds structurels dans le logement
social est également dans le logement
privé et via aussi notamment des
investissements par la banque publique
d'investissement donc ce qu'on appelle
l'abbaye voyez on est en train d'avancer
mais je voudrais juste insister sur un
nouveau fléau parce que je pense que
c'est maintenant qu'il faut tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé avec deux chiffres il
y a aujourd'hui en euros contre 50 125
millions de personnes qui sont dans une
précarité énergétique qui n'arrivent
plus à se chauffer qui n'arrivent plus à
payer notamment leurs factures et ben
c'est une question de rénovation
thermique et va l'europe finance déjà
justement cette rénovation thermique et
a permis en l'espace de deux ans
la rénovation de 70000 logements sociaux
en france et la création directe de plus
de 15000 emplois locaux non
délocalisables m'écouter merci beaucoup
karima delli je rappelle effectivement
que on estime qu'il ya 57 millions
d'européens qui vivent en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté donc effectivement
c'est un grand chantier pour l'union et
pour les parlementaires
merci karima delli d'avoir été notre
invité aujourd'hui nous on continue sur
sur cette émission sur la question de la
syrie vous savez que bachar el-assad est
accusé par la communauté internationale
d'utiliser des armes chimiques dans son
pays et nous avons voulu savoir comment
les télévisions étrangères avait traité
la question c'est un zapping réalisé par
aurélie la face
problèmes respiratoires pupilles
dilatées les blessés des hôpitaux
syriens sont surtout les écrans comme
autant de preuves de l'utilisation des
armes chimiques dans le pays sur la bbc
cette habitante moines il y avait une
odeur suffocante horrible on ne pouvait
plus du tout respire et tout mon corps
était comme fatigué il perdait tous ses
sens on avait l'impression d'être mort
je n'y voyais plus rien et je n'ai plus
rien vu pendant trois ou quatre jours
au plan international les états prennent
position et c'est de s'organiser mais ce
n'est pas encore l'unité
la grande bretagne a annoncé détenir des
preuves sûres concernant l'utilisation
de gaz sarin épreuve confirmée par la
france qui n'exclut pas l'intervention
militaire pendant ce temps la rencontre
entre les etats-unis la russie et l'onu
a débuté à genève pour préparer la
conférence internationale sur la syrie
appelée genève 2 dont la date n'a pas
encore été fixée
pas de date pour une conférence
internationale et au niveau européen
comme toujours pas de position commune
l'embargo sur les armes est levé mais
ensuite libre à chaque état dans livrés
ou non la rtbf juge sévèrement
l'indécision bruxelloise un bisou par ci
un bisou par là devant les caméras les
patrons des différentes diplomatie
européenne donne presque l'impression
d'une parfaite harmonie
ce n'est qu'une illusion une fois réunis
ils affichent leurs divergences pour en
arriver à ce qui s'appelle un échec
les européens en échec sur la question
syrienne c'est nicolas gros verheyde qui
est avec nous pour en parler
merci d'être avec nous bonjour bonjour
vous êtes spécialiste des questions de
défense notamment sur l'union européenne
et partout ailleurs si je puis dire et
vous vous dirigez le blog bruxelles de
poing a eu quand vous voyez ces images
de deux responsables européens qui se
font effectivement la bise et qui sont
dans une certaine léthargie sur la
question syrienne qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
sam aspire que depuis deux ans on parle
de solutions politiques depuis deux ans
les européens en ont mis rien en place
pour une solution politique
du coup on ne discute que l'embargo sur
les armes alors qu'on devrait discuter
plan de paix envoi d'émissaires solution
intermédiaire conférence internationale
ce qui est la solution politique pour
l'instant les européens n'ont mis en
place rien de tout ça et pourtant la
ligue arabe a envoyé un émissaire
filiale a même eu deux ou trois qui ont
chacun démissionner devant
l'impossibilité de la tâche donc est-ce
qu'il ya encore une solution politique
la ligue arabe effectivement pas l'union
européenne oui il ya pour moi il ya
encore on n'a pas essayé tous les tous
les vecteurs de la solution politique le
problème c'est qu'il faut associer tous
les acteurs de la région
donc à part du monde on exclut un des
acteurs qui éliront qui est un acteur
principal
on exclut toute solution politique donc
ça ne sert à rien de parler de solution
politique si on ne dialogue pas en gros
le dialogue
il se passe pas avec les amis il se
passe avec les ennemis donc il faut
associer d'iran il faut associer le
hesbollah le
la partie libanaise et le hezbollah
voire voir toutes les parties vraiment
associer avec des intermédiaires neutre
on peut pas demander au qatar à la
barrière habits saoudite ou à la russie
aux états unis d'être les interminables
neutre faut trouver des intermédiaires
note pour assurer la réunion des deux
parties ce qu'est le classique on
associe le corps arles caen b et au
milieu des neutres les européens où
certains europe 1 aurait pu jouer les
neutres ils ont pas joué les ne trouve
quoi parce qu'ils sont faibles
parce qu'ils sont faibles parce qu'ils
sont impuissants parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas et qu'ils ont le toulonnais sur la
question de la syrie c'est quoi c'est la
régionalisation du conflit on est dans
un espèce de maelström on ne veut pas
s'en mêler
c'est parce que je pense qu'il ya un
manque de volonté au le tout la solution
européenne était dire on appuie les
efforts de l'onu et la ligue arabe
et en gros on fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour ça mais ça ne suffit pas si on veut
être un acteur on doit pas appuyer les
efforts d'un autre acteur on doit
proposer ses services
je pense que là c'est une erreur
fondamentale des européens là on assiste
aussi aujourd'hui à 7 ce franchissement
de la ligne rouge dont barack obama
parlait qui est l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques
on a quand même de plus en plus de
preuves sur l'utilisation notamment du
gaz sarin la question de la levée de
l'embargo et de la livraison d'armes a
été posée qu'en est il en fait de tout
cela alors il y à il ya deux choses il
ya les armes chimiques
la ligne rouge s'était uni rouge bidon
faut aller très clair il n'y a pas de
ligne rouge
y a rien dans le droit international qui
dit que quand yann chimiques on a le
droit d'employer la fin c'est obama qui
l'a dit c'est obama mais nous et on a
fait venir viendra ce mois là mais c'est
une ligne rouge bidon qui et qui
d'ailleurs s'est écroulé au moment la
ligne rouge était franchie
c'est comme quand vous franchissez la
ligne jaune personne n'a sifflé donc
vous pouvez rouler donc il ya eu un feu
vert à l'emploi d'armes chimiques la
ligne rouge et transforma en feu vert ça
c'est le premier fait pour moi la ligne
rouge a déjà été franchi quand on viole
le droit international humanitaire c'est
ça la vraie ligne rouge
la vraie nous rouge combine des hôpitaux
qu'on tue des civils des enfants qu'on
s'attaque aux au médecin après tous les
efforts qu'on ne s'attaque pas
uniquement aux combattants donc la ligne
rouge est franchie depuis de plusieurs
temps la vraie ligne rouge en fait je
pense pour la plupart des acteurs
internationaux c'est que le conflit ne
déborde pas violemment dehors des
frontières
et pourtant la garde on voit que le lion
est quand même un peu touché en tant que
sarlat surgit tant que ça reste un peu
touché savatan qu'en fait pour les
américains la vraie ligne rouge
je pense que c'est israël pour les
russes la vraie ligne rouge chez leurs
bases donc tant ces deux grosses lignes
rouges sont pas franchies personne
personne bougera pas ce que personne n'a
intérêt à bouger les russes bloque toute
façon toute résolution au conseil de
sécurité
les occidentaux ne veulent pas passer en
dehors du conseil de sécurité elles sont
l'irak a payé donc pour l'instant le
conflit continue
il continuera d'avoir des morts on est à
cent mille morts les armes chimiques ont
fait un certain nombre de morts mais
n'ont pas fait l'essentiel des mains
l'essentiel des morts est fait par exams
conventionnelle donc temps que les
syriens se battent dans leur pays pour
la communauté internationale foued
cynique ya pas de problème merci nicolas
gros verheyde d'avoir été notre invité
nous on continue avant de retrouver
kathia gilder et son invité direction la
grèce après 50 crise nous avons été à la
rencontre d'un peuple à l'agonie là bas
le taux de suicide a augmenté de 26% en
une année c'est un reportage de florence
maurice et de pavlos cap anaïs
6 avril 2012 un pharmacien votre été
criblé de dettes se suicident à deux pas
du parlement grec
un geste politique pour dénoncer
l'austérité c'est une honte c'est une
grande honte cela aurait pu être l'un
d'entre nous ça aurait pu être quelqu'un
de notre famille si ça continue nous
allons tous nous suicider les grecs
prennent soudain conscience de la crise
morale qui secoue leur pays a écrit zoo
une association des jo sur endettés on a
pris très tôt la mesure de ce malaise
ici 25 juristes bénévoles viennent en
aide aux victimes des coupes budgétaires
bonjour on va voir où en est votre
dossier mariana a poussé la porte en
à l'époque je me sentais coupable
extrêmement non cropper là je me disais
que j'avais fait beaucoup d'erreurs
j'étais totalement désespéré je ne
sortais plus de la maison je ne voulais
plus me battre je pleurais tout le temps
j'étais envahi par la tristesse et une
profonde envie d'autodestruction parmi
les personnes suivies avec piso quatre
se sont déjà suicidé les bénévoles ont
même dû faire appel à des psychologues
pour les aider à soutenir les plus
désespérés comme beaucoup mariana se
croyait à l'abri
elle était fonctionnaire un emploi
stable bien payé aujourd'hui elle ignore
si elle pourra garder cet appartement
acheté à crédit
après des années de croissance
insouciante en grèce la crise a fait
vaciller ses certitudes
alors hop kavanagh cana en fait je n'ai
rien fait de fou j'ai juste agi comme
tout le monde il faut se souvenir qu'à
cette époque là les banques nous
envoyait des offres de prêts tous les
jours
si marianne a refait surface grâce au
soutien psychologique reçu un épisode
beaucoup n'ont pas cette chance dans une
grèce très religieuse le suicide reste
un sujet tabou
consultez est une décision difficile
coûteuse aussi le secteur de la santé
est à l'agonie un tiers des grecs n'a
plus d'assurance maladie ce centre
médical a été créé en 2011 pour répondre
à l'urgence on n'a pas dîné colog
aujourd'hui si elle donne je dis ici des
médecins bénévoles se relaie pour offrir
gratuitement soins et médicaments aux
exclus du système de santé s'avère
autres feuilles d'acier
merci beaucoup maria et psychologue elle
consulte ici cinq heures par semaine je
sens qu'il ya vraiment des choses qui se
sont débloquées en moi si tous les jours
on voit arriver des bébés de 2 kg alors
qu'ils devraient peser 4 so i know même
beaucoup de gens considèrent le soutien
psychologique comme un luxe dans ce
chaos ambiant
on est en train de fabriquer une
génération de grecs désemparés et en
colère de vider la jeunesse de tout son
potentiel de toutes ses capacités je
n'exagère pas c'est un génocide
en deux ans la consommation
d'antidépresseurs a bondi en grèce celle
de drogue aussi tout comme les
contaminations au vih
deux fois par semaine place omonia
médecins du monde accueille les
toxicomanes et prenait soin de créer la
grèce a même sa nouvelle drogue
l'a6a composé de liquide de batterie et
de détergents j'ai des amis qui en
prennent régulièrement en deux ans
d'utilisation ils sont plus atteints que
moi après 20 ans d'héroïne
je suis déjà allé les voir chez eux ils
deviennent fous il se tape la tête
contre les murs c'est totalement irréel
avoir 2 euros le shoot contre 7 pour de
l'héroïne l'a6a est la drogue de la
crise
tous les indicateurs sont au rouge mais
la grèce s'accroche à ses valeurs
refuges famille et religion depuis le
début de la crise le père thomas est sur
tous les fronts il a triplé ses
distributions de nourriture et multiplie
les activités à destination des enfants
une fois qu'on aura dépassé la crise je
crois que la situation sera meilleure
qu'avant et des femmes car à cause des
difficultés
les gens ont dû renoncer à
l'individualisme absolue et renouer avec
la solidarité c'est quelque chose qu'on
avait perdu
après six années de récession la grèce
espère une timide reprise économique en
mais nul ne sait encore combien de temps
ou de génération il faudra pour réparer
la crise morale qui mine le pays
reportage signé florence maurice à
athènes avec lilly a shoe crise
économique sociale et sanitaire la grèce
est au coeur de l'actualité on en parle
avec notre invité
rodi kratsa bonjour pendant sept députés
grecs du parti populaire européen qui
regroupe la droite et le centre droite
ici au parlement européen vous êtes
membre de la commission des affaires
économiques et monétaires cette semaine
coup de théâtre en grèce puisque il ya
eu une annonce de la fermeture de la
radio télévision publique
la police est monté sur la montagne pour
éteindre l'émetteur principal de la
télévision sans que les journalistes
aient eu le temps de dire au revoir
c'est quand même un cas unique en europe
puisque j'ai vu que la dernière fois que
c'était produit c'était en 1967 avec la
dictature des colonels
est ce que pour vous c'est une violation
de la démocratie
du côté ne fait pas des comparaisons
pareil la grèce est un pays en récession
économique sixième année de récession
économique est une société en crise
comme votre reportage a évoqué de
l'autre côté il y à une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui chez les grecs
je sais pas si votre reportage a pu
constater ça aussi les garçons dont les
reflets saut dans les réunions dans les
familles autour de la famille pour des
fêtes familiales pour des fêtes
religieuses elles ont une confiance en
l'avenir malgré la tristesse malgré la
souffrance et la sur cbs ce qu'elle veut
fermer
vous imaginez comment alors la décision
il a la situation difficile que le
gouvernement après tant de tentatives de
restaurer le shakhtar publique de
radiotélévision est un secteur à nord
l'ont productique nos compétitive a pris
la décision après des grèves continuent
parce que mam malgré son fonctionnement
en ligne et mettait pas toujours et
partout à cause de grève continue il a
pris la décision de fermer les secteurs
et de préparer déjà le projet là la loue
verture la création d'un autre secteur
avec moindre de personnes au moins de
personnel mais sur instructeur plus
rationalisée des structures modernes qui
pourra a quand même satisfaire aux
besoins d'un service public et qui ne va
peser autant aux contribuables grecs
est ce que le gouvernement grec qui a
surpris tout le monde de court en
prenant cette décision n'aurait pas pu
quand même informé avant les salariés
puisque même l'union européenne a été
surprise le président de l'ufr union des
radios télés l'isthme du combat a
critiqué cette décision
vous convenez compris je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas vous parler de la
communication du laïc cette
communication entre les secteurs publics
grecs
l association européenne ça je ne peux
pas vous dire que c'était déjà leur
avais inévitable ça je ne vais pas vous
dire c'est qu'ils étaient nécessaires
c'est pour ça que malgré les réactions
des fonctionnaires qu'on peut très bien
comprendre quelqu'un qui bacs son
travail et il a quand même dans une
partie de la grèce de la population des
îles satisfaction que quand même il ya
un bouleversement qui va rationaliser le
secteur public parce que pour le moment
les effets de la crise de l'austérité de
cette adaptation rapide budgétaire c'est
là le secteur privé tibet
équilibre à le chômage c'est dans les
secteurs privés alors si on demande aux
entreprises privées de faire leur
restructuration de rationaliser de faire
des exportations des faire plus de
choses avec moi
- du mouvement des frais imaginez
comment ces charters privé qui voit
baiser sur ses épaules cette adaptation
à cette crise et exige du gouvernement
de m de faire mieux son ménage dont les
secteurs publics mais malgré ça il y a
une une prise à des précautions pour les
fonctionnaires deux grands secteurs de
radio télévision
ils ne seront pas dehors ils seront
hissés rond il s'enlise enfants quand
même d'abord une priorité pour les
concours d'entrée dans l'aisne
la nouvelle structure qui va naître on
espère bien bientôt et de l'autre côté
ils peuvent aussi passer de les concours
ou des services qui embauchent encore
comme les hôpitaux les services sociaux
etc
quand on voit notre reportage on se dit
que l'état du pays et quand même
et quand même grave et dia est difficile
société en crise mais certains voient
pourtant économistes prédisent un retour
de la croissance en 2014
est ce que vous y croyez aux niçois on
espère on travaille pour ça
mais vous savez il faut prendre des
mesures difficiles des décisions
difficiles et cette balance cet
équilibre constant que le gouvernement
doit faire nous en trop ah la la
la rationalisation économique et
budgétaire est quand même la protection
des travailleurs de la société des gens
de chômeurs est toujours difficile vous
pouvez comprendre comment ceci comment
c'est difficile de prendre des mesures
que nous on les voit urgent et
nécessaire parce que il aura un coût
social et politique y est ce qui est
très souvent insupportable voilà nous on
en a tous les jours des décisions de
pareilles décisions apprend en même
temps les politiques ont été appliquées
pour la grèce depuis des années son sont
un peu remise en cause le fonds
monétaire international a lui même
reconnu qu'il avait peut-être fait
fausse route en imposant une austérité
aussi aussi forte est ce que c'est le
cas voilà vous savez moi je critiquais
même d'un cerveau plateau plusieurs fois
elle le programme appliqué en grèce au
début tout le monde a cru que c'était la
troïka qui a l'expérience internationale
de l union monétaire est bon la centrale
qui ont une expérience internationale
l intérêt de voir des résultats positifs
rapidement et les programmes et les bons
il faut les suivre
nous notre parti a contesté de le
premier moment
ce programme est parce que les graines
et les par contre le n 19 bat il n'était
pas équilibrée dans les deux volets
austérité et et mesure des soutenances
de l'économie est de 2,60 croissance oui
mais voilà on est là aujourd'hui il faut
s'en sortir et c'est très difficile pour
la classe politique et pour la société
grecque
c'est nos soucis quotidiens mais c'était
je peux vous dire c'est que vraiment le
gouvernement doit aller en avant apple
souhaite et il n'a pas le choix d'aller
en arrière mais la société grecque
ll est très solidaire vous l'avez pu
constater que cette solidarité vraiment
elle est très nécessaire ou donner cet
espoir aux gens non seulement de
supporter les phares de leur plan pour
le lendemain
eh bien merci beaucoup rudi garcia ce
sera zéro
votre intérêt de l'intérêt que vous
portez à la société doit vous laisser
aller dans l'hémicycle puisqu'il ya des
votes en ce moment même c'est la fin de
cette émission je vous souhaite une très
bonne suite de programmes et rendez vous
la semaine prochaine sur les chaînes
parlementaires pour un autre numéro de
rap hebdo